(applause)
- Kirsten you just got
your star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame as well.
(applause)
- Yes.
- Which is huge.
- Now that was weird!
- Which-
But how, I mean, I've been
to one of them before cause Simon
got his and I spoke at his
and I was like it's crazy.
- You don't have one yet?
- I, you know, honestly,
I would feel, I don't know I feel weird
- You're going to get one.
- about my- me being on a gr-
I don't know.
- I know what you mean.
- How do you feel about it?
- I know what you-
I was, I would wake up with anxiety
like every day for a week
cause I hate public speaking.
I was very nervous.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So the morning of, like, I did
have a glass of wine at like ten thirty
in the morning, which I don't think
I've ever done
- You gotta do what you gotta
do.
- Before in my life.
I needed it!
And then, it was very silent in the car.
It was just, it's very hot
and like, it's just, an emotional-
you have everyone who you love there
it's almost like a wedding or a funeral
too, in a way.
- Yeah.
- It's just very intense.
So you're giving your speeches
- Two very different
functions, but yes.
(audience laughs)
- Yes, yeah, yeah!
But just-
- Unless you're marrying
someone you don't wanna marry.
- Oh, God.
(audience laughs)
- That might be your funeral.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
- But how did y'all celebrate?
- We went to Musso & Frank's after
which is a very classic Hollywood place
if you haven't been, go, it's-
- I haven't been.
- You haven't? It's-
- No, I don't go out.
- I understand, so, well, like I said
I only go out when I
have like a thing to do
so, I like, we had marti-
I didn't even eat then, either.
I was just feeding my son spaghetti
and pounding martinis
(audience laughs)
so I was like-
- This is how you celebrate!
That's amazing.
- That's how we celebrate.
With all our friends and family.
We actually almost got married too.
We almost called a Justice of the Peace.
(Kelly laughs)
- To Musso & Frank's
because we were all there already,
and like we hadn't made
it official yet, so,
we almost did that but we
couldn't get it in time.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- That's crazy, I love y'all.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Kirsten laughs)
- How spontaneous.
But after you got your
star a news outlet tweeted-
this is amazing.
(Kelly laughs)
That you're best known as
Spiderman's girlfriend?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which I was like,
(audience cheers)
- I mean a great shot,
it was a great movie.
- Well-
- Yeah but still like-
- But that's not what I feel
like you're best known as.
- I- Thank you, thank you.
Also-
- That's like saying Meryl
Streep's best is like, you know,
Death Becomes Her.
Which is great!
- I love that movie, but.
- But like, maybe Out of Africa
or Sophie's Choice.
- It's just movie-
I was just so, it's just weird too
because I, like, just say Mary Jane
at least, or something.
It's just like the girlfriend.
- You just got girlfriend.
- Yeah I remember the second Spiderman
it was like the poster was my face
and Spiderman's face, like-
(laughs)
You know what I mean?
I'm like-
But yeah, it was, it was nice
that everyone came to my defense.
- They did!
- I know I really appreciated
that.
- They came to your defense-
They actually came to your
defense in a very funny way.
Twitter blew up with people going after
how sexist that was,
here's one tweet
- It was.
- it said, it is yeah,
Kirsten Dunst could do Once Upon
A Time but Leonardo DiCaprio couldn't do
Bring it On.
But here's the thing.
(audience cheers)
- Maybe he could actually.
- But here's the thing:
Who wants to see Leonardo DiCaprio
do Bring it On?
- I do! I do. (Kelly laughs)
- That was hilarious.
- Because I actually think
that was funny. Well I didn't
like how all the tweets,
cause there were tons of tweets
like defending you about that,
well I didn't like how they
were negative against the guys,
cause those guys are really talented.
At the same time, that never happens
to guys.
- No it doesn't, you're right.
- It always happens to women.
- Yeah.
- I hate, like, beating a dead horse
in the public eye where I
keep talking about it but-
- And they're never compared
to eachother, men, either,
you never compare them,
and we're always being compared.
- I know, I don't understand this.
- It's a combination-
- Is it cause we're so awesome
the spotlight just gravitates?
(Kirsten laughs)
(audience cheers)
- It's probably cause we're awesome.
- That's a nice, yeah, yeah.
- Because they do that with women
in music as well.
- Oh, of course.
- And I'm like, is it because
y'all just don't matter?
And we do?
I'm just gonna filter that way.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- I'm just- but anyway,
but how did you feel, like I always feel
really good when my fans come to my-
cause they went after people.
- I do too are you kidding me?
I was like, oh thank-
Like it feels so nice to be appreciated
for your work.
- Yeah.
- And I have been doing
this for so long and-
and so you-
- Way longer than just Spiderman.
- Yeah, exactly, since
I was three years old.
- Yeah!
- Um, so.
- That's like if people were like:
you're greatest thing
was From Justin to Kelly.